hi this is an interview with the authors
of the paper evolving curricula with
regret based environment design if you
haven't seen it i've made a review of
this paper yesterday the day before this
video is released and i went over the
paper in detail and explained what's
inside of it so if you haven't seen that
it would be a good place to start today
i'm interviewing the authors of this
paper jack and minchi who are real
experts in this domain now during the
interview we go a lot deeper than i
could do myself in the paper review and
you learn a lot more about how things
work in this paper but also in the
entire field it's a very exciting field
and it's a real privilege to be able to
interview all of these people i hope
you're having fun please let me know in
the comments how i can make these videos
better for you and thank you to everyone
who does watch who does comment who does
share thank you to all the supporters on
patreon to all the discord members and
to everyone else who is excited by
machine learning i hope you're doing
well stay hydrated now let's get into
the interview
jack parker holder and ming chi chiang
did i get this right
yeah thank you um welcome very much to
the show
thanks for having us
let's see
you i think your paper here it was of
one one sort an example of a very cool
paper uh because it's not honestly it's
a bit out of the mainstream usually
reinforcement learning tackles improving
the agent as much as possible
where you you go much into this road of
poet and work before it improving the
environment but also i think it's a good
lesson in how to kind of put a bit of
publicity behind the paper because you
made this this very cool website right
here when this with the interactive demo
where i can play around with the terrain
right well okay if it only works um and
you have these these kind of nice
animations of how things develop during
training and so on uh and i think like
how much do you think something like
this helps a paper after it's released
like what was your impression of
you know just just kind of or or maybe
you can tell me a little bit how did you
how did you even decide paper aside to
make a website like this and present it
in a form that's interactive
i i think with rl research um
especially when you look at curriculum
design you're modifying the environments
there's always really interesting
visualizations that you can share but i
think having just like the standard pdf
format that everyone publishes on
archivin is really really limiting and
there's just so much um there's so much
amazing like assets you can actually
share in terms of your agent behavior in
terms of the emergent complexity that
these algorithms generate so we really
wanted to share that uh with readers and
we thought that would definitely capture
more of people's imaginations um when
they engage with our work and there's
like also just a huge um
sort of lineage of work that tries to do
a similar thing like our template for
this website is actually taken from uh
distill so uh distill pub has
so many great works and they they put so
much effort into making such beautiful
interactive publications and we
definitely took a lot of inspiration
from that um david ha google brain has a
bunch of publications like with world
models attention agent that did similar
things
yeah and then also we used the teach my
agent uh work from the flowers lab as
well which had some of the like building
blocks for this and that was really cool
but i think the the other thing is like
there's always this question with these
type of methods if you picked the test
environments where your method works and
as reviewers ourselves we're always very
cynical of this and so we kind of
thought what if we just let people try
and break it and see what happens and of
course you can break it pretty easily
and that actually leads to kind of
exciting questions of how you can make
it better in future work but at the same
time it's kind of nice to see how it
does and doesn't work because at the end
of the day i think we should be more
honest about the robustness of our
agents and this is quite a nice tool to
not only make it fun but also kind of
demonstrate it
i think more also for
not just for readers but i think just
for ourselves as researchers like in the
process of making this tool and starting
to actually run the agent in tons of
visualized environments we actually
started to discover certain shortcomings
of the agent like you can look at all
these plots all day long and you see all
the metrics go up into the right but
then you don't actually see sort of the
blind spots that come up uh during
training until you actually visualize it
and we discovered a few interesting
motifs that uh that consistently
challenged the agent even though it's
overall quite robust
yeah because we're actually going to
talk we're talking about maybe like
making it so that it defaulted to levels
that we know it can do well on but then
we just thought it kind of removes the
fun
and at the end of the day if it breaks
and someone's inspired to improve it
that's ultimately a good thing so
yeah i mean you do you do have the
metrics to prove that it does something
well right and uh anything after that is
a bonus essentially
how did you how did you get even into
this yeah how did you get even into this
into this field do you maybe want to um
like give a 30 second bio of yourself
like how did you arrive at this point
sure so i mean from my perspective
um poet came out before my phd and i
thought it was really inspirational
really cool work but um i didn't really
know if i'd ever get to work on
something like that
and then obviously interning last summer
at a meta with um tim and ed and minchi
uh who all on paper and maker as well
the group was working on generalization
and starting to improve on idea and
build on ideas such as like pairs and
these other algorithms
and so then so when i came in we were
talking a little bit about uh like
shortcomings of our methods and then
poet obviously comes up as another
example and we were kind of thinking how
do we take some of the ideas from poet
and really incorporate it into our
existing uh like regret-based curriculum
methods and so then it became the kind
of obvious that we want to try this
environment and this type of work i
guess it was kind of a fusion of
different things so it was like top down
initially and then also ended up being
bottom-up
yeah and um i guess uh curriculum
learning was something i kind of
stumbled on and the first year of my phd
and basically i was originally trying a
bunch of uh sort of random ideas of uh i
always had this notion that maybe rl
could be made more efficient if you
trained agents on um levels that were
just within reach and then you basically
progressively increased um the level
complexity in terms of a curriculum and
so we worked on a prior method as well
called prioritize level replay which is
this uh pink plr uh baseline here and
that one ended up doing quite well
especially when combined with data
augmentation on the open eye proc gene
benchmark
and so
right after that um i got in touch with
uh another researcher at uc berkeley um
a fellow named michael dennis and he was
one of the first authors on the emerging
complexity uh for zero shot um
robustness paper uh that introduced the
paired algorithm and so this is a this
is the paper that kind of introduced a
lot of the formal theory decision theory
around mini max regret policies uh in
their application within the rl and it
kind of was the first paper that showed
that if you optimize for mini max regret
in using dbrl it makes sense and you get
nice experimental results that show
robustness and zero shot transfer and so
we started discussing and we realized
that actually a lot of theory could be
applied to plr and that plr was actually
another instantiation of this mini max
regret game which is at the heart of
this theory and um and excel is sort of
like
you know the latest version it's sort of
the culmination of the ideas we've
explored so far um in this direction
yeah i guess it's worth noting that we
we published through us plr paper at
europe's last year um so that was really
that was finishing just around june july
time when i joined um meta yeah and so
really we were looking we kind of knew
that method was very empirically strong
and theoretically nice but it still
maybe lacked something in that it
couldn't really have some creative
process to design its own levels because
it could only sample i think as you as
you pointed out in your review
um so ultimately if the space is very
high dimensional and you're in example
one high regret level once you've
mastered it you have to then go back to
the drawing board whereas the nice thing
about excel is that inspired by poet it
can really kind of build its own
complexity over time
and so it really is kind of like a
progression through um it's a really
sequence of papers i guess and
and prevent michael's been on now three
three of them in a row because he was
unpaired and then robust
now excel can you give like a layman's
layman's explanation for
optimizing for minimax regret
because there there are a bunch of like
it's regret and then max and then min uh
what's
what does it ultimately boil down to
like uh yeah
so so um so
this largely comes from this emerging
complexity paper uh from michael dennis
and natasha jacks um essentially the
theory there is essentially framing um
framing a concept called unsupervised
environment design as essentially this
problem where you want to design
environments that maximize for some
metric and that metric is usually some
behavioral metric that's associated with
the student agent and so in this game in
this mini master get game we care about
maximizing the regret of the agent
and so if you frame the game as a game
where it's a two-player game it's
zero-sum the payoff for the student is
the negative regret and the payoff for
the teacher is the positive regret um
essentially you have a game where the
teacher tries to increase the regret of
the student and the students try to
minimize its regret so if you think
about two-player zero-sum games
they always have a nash equilibrium and
at the nash equilibrium of this game
it's got to be the policy that the
student plays that essentially is a
minimax regret policy it's minimizing
its worst case regret because if it's
not doing this the teacher must be able
to change its policy and play more of a
certain level that further increases the
regret and so by definition at a nash
equilibrium neither player has an
improving uh response so it must be that
the student has a mini max regret policy
so what does that mean in layman's terms
it basically means that the student
behaves in a way
that essentially it's able to do well in
any level that's solvable inside of the
parametrized space of tasks that the
teacher can use um to propose the next
level
so the yes it should always be
sorry
the teacher would have oh this is
um the teacher's moves was essentially
be the levels like the actions of the
teacher would be i play this level
yeah yeah so it's within this
abstraction uh called a upon dp which is
just like a partially observable markov
decision process but you add an
additional set of variables called the
free parameters uh in the papers we
usually use the term theta to denote
them and so they those are like the
positions of where the obstacles are in
the maze in the maze domain uh might be
like starting position of the agent goal
position um inside of the a car racing
environment it might be like the
position of where the tracks are um and
so these are the design parameters and
so a strategy of the teacher is
essentially like choose some
distribution over choices of the
possible
free parameters that it can sample as
the next level sorry jack you go
all right
i'm just going to say like the nice
intuitive property of this is that it
makes the agent has to learn to solve
all of the simplest solvable
environments as well so in some other
methods like poet they're trying to
achieve the maximum complexity
which is like it's very cool as well
motivated but this is quite different in
that we're actually happy if even later
in training our agents training on
simple levels if it means that it can
solve all of the simple levels because
we don't we don't really care as much
about solving like crazy complex things
if it breaks on a simple thing um which
i think is seems to make sense at least
to me yeah that was one of my let's say
worries right here is that if you if you
uh
and i i framed this a little bit as you
are at this zone of proximal development
with your agent in that
i somehow made it wrong like you you try
to reach levels that are just outside of
where the agent can handle it and then
you you try to edit those a little bit
or maybe just where the agent can handle
them and then you try to edit them a
little bit and you try to filter by the
ones that
pass some threshold in this estimated
regret so my first question would be
coming back to this regret you you
formulate it as the
um so it's it's formulated as the
difference to the optimal policy right
uh the difference to to the optimal
policy i'm gonna guess on this
particular level that you're at uh
why doesn't this like disregard the
approximation that you do if i could
calculate this very accurately wouldn't
this select for super duper difficult
levels uh that that could be solved with
the optimal policy right not impossible
but just super difficult ones that's a
great question um i think part of the
part of the nuanced detail here is that
so one reason that makes this all work
is the discount factor
so basically um so in the original paper
uh that introduced paired and this idea
of the minimax regret game um the reward
function for that environment actually
um it actually
your reward your final return decreases
with the length of your trajectory
and so there's a natural discounting in
terms of the return and so essentially
by doing mini max regret it ends up
prioritizing for those levels where the
solutions within reach in the fewest
number of steps
and you get this nice curriculum but
because here in all of our approximate
single agent regret estimators we're
using a value function which is
bootstrapped off of a generalized
advantage estimator which itself is
discounted
you essentially have discounting built
into your value function and so you end
up with discounting even if they're even
if your environment's a final you know
sparse reward no discounting naturally
in the external reward um you still get
discounting because your value function
is going to be discounting
using gamma and if you use ga you have
further discounting with lambda
cool
uh yeah that was one of my one of the
things that i didn't exactly
understand uh here in this okay i i i
was like disregard the discount factors
they're not important turns out they're
actually one of the most important parts
right here to actually make it work um
although you use uh you use this this
positive
value loss now i i think you wrote me in
an email before that i got this wrong in
the
um
in the paper review do you want to maybe
quickly discuss what the individual
parts of this formula mean and what they
do
i mean so uh essentially
the uh
i guess we can start from sort of the
outside in i guess or maybe it makes
sense to do the inside out so basically
the innermost term is um essentially
just a td error it's the one step td
error
and it's future facing so it's from your
current time step t until the horizon t
capital t okay um and essentially the
inner the the inner term except for uh
outs within the max that term is
basically um
if you look at the sum from t to capital
t that's basically the generalized
advantage estimator from um schumann at
all and so that one is the most com
that's the advantage estimator used in
ppo um it's used in other policy
gradient algorithms as well um but
essentially that is essentially
estimating uh your advantage while
trying to do a trade-off between um
one-step td errors being more biased
because it's bootstrapping off of fewer
steps and longer td errors being less
biased but having more variance and so
lambda is a discount factor that
controls for that um and so in a
nutshell though this is estimating
advantage which is basically this is my
actual return minus uh my typical return
which could you can think of as what the
value function outputs um and so the
zero so this is sorry this is return
minus
return minus value
yeah you can think of it as the return
you achieved minus your value prediction
at each step in your trajectory and we
average it over the trajectory yeah and
essentially that's telling us um if
that's really high it means that i'm
doing better than what i typically do
and so directionally this is like in the
direction of regret because it means
that extra there's in terms of external
regret i can actually get a higher
return than i typically do which means
that this is a level where i experience
regret um and then we max this with zero
which just means that we are only
looking at the positive time steps where
at the time steps at which this term is
positive so we're only looking when the
agent does better than it typically does
and if on average when it does better
than it typically does is quite high it
means that's a level where the agent can
experience a lot of regret in its
decision making
how so though like my logic was a little
bit uh if i if i
if i'm worse than i estimated that means
kind of it's a difficult level like
where's my where's my thinking wrong
here
so if you're worse then
you're if you do worse than you
estimated um i think in terms of just
the mini match regret framework it's
just a little bit uh
sideways from
in terms of measuring the direction of
regret i think if you think of it as
looking for cases where you do better
than you typically do that's really just
you discovering regret it's like you
discovered a case where um you achieve
regret relative to your typical self
like as as sort of uh amortized by this
value function that predicts like how
well you typically do over time um so
with respect to sort of like this
average prediction of yourself you
do you're doing better and so you're
essentially discovering sources of new
regret in this level um
and that's that's like basically
directionally aligned with maximizing
regret while if you were to do the
opposite if you were to say i want to
look for the steps where um i do worse
than i think i do um i think that's an
interesting thing to try actually but i
don't at least theoretically it doesn't
seem to align with minnie mac's regret
as well yeah okay i can see the the
logic in that you say i want to find
levels where there's something
unexpected positive thing happening
yeah i guess it's worth noting as well
that impaired which was the first ud
algorithm to use regret they had a very
different approaches which had a second
agent called an antagonist and the
regret was just the difference in
performance between those two
and so maybe that's like
a bit more intuitive because if the
antagonist can solve a level and the
protagonist the student agent can't
then i guess that's more intuitive in
terms of what you expect from regret but
the nice thing about this is it's kind
of a cheap approximate for single agent
to regret and we definitely feel like
maybe coming up with better metrics
for single agent regret is exciting
future work that could be improved upon
here but this was taken just from their
basketball paper and we were surprised
how well it worked in quite different
environments so
um and another detail is um in the
robust plr work another regressive meter
we used uh that we explored
was what we call maximum monte carlo
regret estimator and essentially it's
the same it's almost the same um
expression except uh the regret target
is no longer what you just received
inside of a recent episodic rollout it's
for every level we keep track of the
highest return you ever achieved
throughout training on that level and we
use that as an estimate for the maximum
performance on that level and then we
use that as the target to subtract your
value prediction on and so that's like a
more off policy regret which i think in
some cases might be better because it's
less coupled to your current policy
while the positive value loss it's
always what you recently received in a
roll out in terms of your target minus
your value function prediction
yeah
is is that is that worth because you
would introduce some extra variants
because you're not essentially
subtracting your own
like you use this as a baseline in the
advantage estimate
or am i am i seeing this wrong so this
would introduce extra variance
it's not using the policy update it's
used just to score the levels yeah okay
so essentially essentially you're saying
the best you've ever done
which might be more it's more it's going
to upper bound your current performance
right um the best you've ever done
including your current performance um
versus your value function so it's it's
slightly nicer in a sense that if you've
experienced a level many times maybe
you've had some forgetting then the
regret should be higher because you've
done well in the past but but the
negative is you have to then store all
of your previous episodes for every
level and then oftentimes you don't
actually have any previous experience so
it's not even that applicable but
there's there's a trade-off and i think
again i think there's something that
could be improved in future work so
i mean especially with procedurally
generated content it's
it's probably hard like you'd have to
you'd have to build some sort of a even
a model to estimate the best possible
regret given past procedurally generated
levels to sort of predict for for any
new one and those two models will
probably make
similar sorts of mistakes like the
mistakes might even be correlated
between the
okay um
so with respect to to your your method
here which is is decently simple what i
was surprised by is that you
deliberately go away
from the teacher being its own agent
right
the teacher here is is a let's say a
fixed algorithm it has some randomized
components with the level editing and so
on but
i think the this differs from a lot of
these kind of curriculum approaches
where people try to make the teacher
deliberately into its own agent and try
to to sort of
frame the adversarial setting in terms
of two learning things doing self-play
what what kept you from doing like are
you are you still convinced
are you still convinced that um
this might be a good way or are you also
looking into the direction of making the
teacher kind of a learnable component
yes so so i guess the first thing to say
is that when we started this project we
actually did envisage ourselves using a
learned editor yeah
and that was like what personally what i
was really excited about at the
beginning was having maybe even a
population of editors that make
different edits learn somehow maybe to
compete with each other
but the first thing we tried was the
simplest thing and often you hear this
in research that the simple thing worked
surprisingly well
and so we didn't really feel the need to
really go beyond when we got results in
mini grid initially that were better
than anything we've seen before
um
we felt that it's actually better to go
with a simpler approach and maybe in the
future we could consider ways to improve
this by adding more learned components
because that has been the trend
elsewhere
but i think going from random sampling
to evolution enough it was was enough to
like significantly improve based on the
previous work um so we didn't need to go
all the way to learn edits as well but
eventually has some additional uh
thoughts on this yeah i totally agree i
think the
simplicity of it just was but it was
pleasantly surprising that such a simple
method could unlock such a big gain in
performance
um
in terms of uh treating the teacher as
an agent i guess a lot of where this our
this work derives from is uh this
paired method which did treat the
teacher as an agent um and actually the
teacher was trained using reinforcement
learning um
and
from from based on all the empirical
results that we've sort of so far
collected in the process of writing
these papers um one thing that we have
seen is that it seems that rl is not a
very efficient way to train an agent to
to solve this problem of presenting
always the most challenging
task for a student and i think the
reason is because it's such a highly
non-stationary problem
basically throughout training your
students going to get better at certain
things maybe get worse at others and the
policy is always evolving it's very
non-stationary so to be able to always
track where in the parameter space will
correspond to the levels that maximally
challenge that of non-stationary policy
i think that's a very hard problem for
rl to solve
especially given how sample inefficient
rl can be and so what i think one of the
reasons why methods like random sampling
that plr does it works so well is
because it's really able to escape sort
of the limitations of rl and just
directly sample for points in the space
and you're also not locally bound to
like just only being able to move a
small amount based on a gradient step
you can really just sample anything um
anywhere in the space because it's
randomly searching and then the curator
just creates the best ones
um so i think that at least within these
types of domains we've looked at um this
type of like random search plus
evolution strategy just definitely
outperforms a learned teacher
in
your
in your architecture i found
you mentioned a bunch of times that you
are relatively
independent of domain specific
heuristics and things like this
specifically you criticized poet for for
uh choosing like an arbitrary range of
returns of you know
they they just select levels between
where the agents achieve between 50 and
300 which they claim to be you know hard
but not hard but not too hard
and
yet i find for example in your algorithm
you need something like well we only put
something into the buffer if the regret
is above a certain threshold couldn't i
leverage kind of the same criticism to
you and say well probably that threshold
is going to be problem specific right
and uh it's it's kind of it's kind of a
hyperparameter that doesn't seem like
it's dependent on the environment but
is it
i think you're right that
this is dependent on the domain but i'll
say the specific point about the
hyperparameter um that one is actually a
bit more uh
benevolent of a issue i think because um
that's actually not a hyper parameter in
our method uh it's just whatever is the
lowest score inside the buffer is the
threshold okay um but i think that's
definitely
i think
like i think if someone like you uh i
think
read it that way i think we should
definitely reword that in the paper i
think that's definitely going to be an
improvement to clarity on that point um
but it's basically the threshold is
basically whatever is the lowest score
in the level buffer and if it's better
than the lowest one we replace it so
it's kind of like a priority queue in
terms of the regret um the thing that
i but i agree with you i think that
methods like excel and methods that
basically require you to directly modify
levels to construct them i think these
types of methods are always going to be
domain specific because i think at the
end of the day you need to have a way of
parameterizing the environment and
that's domain knowledge and you need to
parameterize how you're editing that
level
yeah i guess the editing itself is also
i think it's more
there's probably more domain knowledge
than one one cares to admit because
yeah you think like okay in block world
i'm just modifying one block to be there
or not right but there is a decision of
you know do i modify one block do i
modify a block of blocks do i place a
wall an entire wall or not and things
like this and depending on how much you
edit because you have this assumption
right which uh is that if i modify if i
make
like my modifications need to be small
enough such they don't they don't
influence the hardness of the level too
much yet they need to be large enough
such that they do bring some variation
into the picture right and that balance
do you think that balance it might be
easy in
these kinds of levels
what like how how do you find this
balance in more challenging problems
like
i don't know if you guys if you think
further yeah
so i guess in these problems it's worth
noting that for the block situation the
actual domain randomization process
places the blocks one at a time so all
we're really doing is kind of saying you
have a few more steps of that initial
process so it is fairly aligned with the
the whole problem there and and then in
both and then in the bipedal walker
setting we're just making small changes
to the encoding vector
and in both settings we we have these
details of this in the appendix if you
dare to venture but in both settings we
did sort of a sweep over the number of
edits you can make in one go
and in both and in both cases we found
that all of the values worked well
uh we we obviously picked the one that
was the best performing on our
validation sets but
it didn't it seemed fairly robust to the
number of edits you make and the thing
worth noting again there is that what
you could do is if for example you don't
care as much about the number of samples
you use to find a high regret level
you could just try try all of these
values in one batch and then because
with plr based methods you just curate
the ones that i regret you could say
okay i'm gonna do some with one edit
some with two some with three some with
four or whatever it might be
and you could almost scale the size of
the edits and then just from that batch
just take the high regret ones and
you're probably still gonna have
more new high regret levels than you
would if you randomly sampled from the
initial distribution
um so i think that there is some
flexibility to do something like that
um and i'd argue that you could frame a
lot of things uh in this editing sort of
framework and i think we mentioned a
couple of examples like perturbing
latent latency and generative model for
example
that may be a bit seen as more general
than specific encodings for environments
it is a good point i want to stick on
this a little bit the
the types of problems where these
methods are applicable because they seem
very general yet it feels like you need
a problem where
you can construct such a curriculum and
that curriculum needs to be fairly
smooth let's say so that the difficulty
increase needs to be manageable and so
on and uh also the regret the way you
calculate regret with the with the td
error uh it means that
probably an environment like the walker
where i you know i get more reward the
further i go
uh is probably more conducive than
something like a montezuma's revenge
even though i have a td error and so on
that kind of smooths out the loss itself
can you comment a little bit on what
kind of problems would like
where would it start to struggle
um like where would you probably have
trouble applying something like this and
where would it work obviously works
super well on these types of things that
you tried it on but where would it
struggle
yeah i think you're right it's it's got
a ha it's got to be a domain where you
do have
some structure um that progressively
gets you know goes from simpler to more
complex um
and it's i guess one nice benefit of
these methods is that you don't need to
know ahead of time what exactly does it
mean for a level in this domain to be
hard easy or hard um because we have
this regret based heuristic to tell us
that and
if you do have sort of this progressive
structure within the domain um then
these methods can sort of start to merge
that um based on this heuristic but i
think that at least with these plr based
methods because the core is still needle
in the haystack you're looking for high
regret levels by random search and then
evolution in excel just massively
augments that in terms of the amount of
training data you can get from high
regret levels but
the bottleneck step is still sort of
like this limitation around at some
point you still have to just get that
needle in the haystack um and so i think
as the design space like the
dimensionality of your environment gets
bigger and bigger i would expect that um
i would expect that these methods become
less and less efficient
do you have a couple of a couple
oh sorry
i think we have like a one second lag or
so
all right sorry so i guess one other
thing one perspective of this is it's
really just a black box optimization
problem where the the function returns
regret
and so we've gone from random sampling
to evolution but if you look at black
box optimization literature there are
plenty of methods that trade off between
global and local optimization in a more
like elegant way and so what you could
do is have some some model or approach
that maybe samples points
more like diversely in the space
and then you use something like excel
locally to make edits once you found uh
that needle in haystack that then she
mentioned
and then the second thing is that i
think one place where this might break
down is because it is quite a kind of
greedy local optimization process is if
you haven't got sort of a very um clear
like high to low um sort of environment
then maybe you need something to
encourage diversity so you need to maybe
have some sort of like either buffer
could be maybe like hierarchical or
something or
um you could try and preserve levels
that you think are conducive to edits
later on even if they're not the current
high regret levels
um and these are all ideas we've talked
about future work
i think really what we need is we need
to have these more challenging problems
uh to actually break our current methods
before we can really think of
the hammer for these nails
but yeah
well what is a bit special as well is
that you train a single agent right
because usually the evolutionary methods
they are trying to get a population of
agents to work even if they want to end
up with a single agent um very often and
you encode all of this into a single
agent and that's kind of a ppo really
basic
agent if i want to say and i have
noticed a little bit that in these
demonstrations no matter what the level
is kind of the strategy
tends to be the same right it tends to
kind of it tends to hop on this one leg
with the other one with the other one
out and that is sort of the best
strategy to overcome any and all
obstacles
um and then kind of rebalance itself
once it's yeah this one see
so
yeah
maybe maybe we've been walking wrong our
whole lives who knows
but no i mean it's it's it's obvious if
you if you instill this in a single
agent how how much of a how much because
i also observed some of your results
here over time which was also really
cool to see when you compare to the uh
to the poet algorithm in that
you do get kind of more challenging
levels later on but they also like they
don't dominate it doesn't get more and
more and more and more challenging right
how much of this is a property of like
catastrophic forgetting of the agent
itself where you kind of push for the
more complicated levels but all of a
sudden it can't can't solve the easy
ones anymore and therefore the easy ones
become high regret and then there's kind
of this
like how much of this is due to your
algorithm and how much of this is due to
the fact that you have a single agent
trained with ppo that needs to take care
of all of these tasks at the same
you know time guess is it's the latter
part because i think that having this
buffer that we do have which um
in the robust plr and the previous plr
paper
um it does somewhat help with forgetting
because you're able to sample things you
haven't seen for a while and if and if
you now can't solve them as well or um
or if you now have higher regret in
these levels then you should retrain on
them so it should somewhat eliminate
forgetting but i do think it's worth
noting that this agent is just a two
hidden layer uh neural net policy it's
not not very flexible it's pretty like
low dimensional
and i think it really is unable to adapt
to every different possible behavior
and so i think either having something
where you can co-evolve the architecture
as well to maybe make it more flexible
as the levels get harder or even just
making your agent be a some sort of
adaptive
agent like a meta learning algorithm for
example that does zero shot adaptation
i think these approaches are things that
we're excited about maybe for future
work yeah but i think for this it's sort
of an inevitability that when you try
and have this like lofty goal of having
a generally capable agent it's going to
have some brittleness to some certain
components i think we found a few cases
like yeah uphill it's not particularly
good yeah when we started visualizing it
in this viewer that we have in the demo
uh we noticed that you know like when we
were training this thing all the
complexity metrics for like roughness of
the ground it started going up very
quickly um but then when we actually
printed out a lot of the levels where
it's successful they tend to be levels
uh where it's all downhill which means
that this pogo stick strategy it's very
good at just like hopping down the hill
and it's really robust at landing like
just sticking the landing in terms of
like really high eclipse but when you
start to get more like these rugged
hills uh going uphill where the slope is
positive um that's where it starts to
struggle so that's like a really
interesting and i think a very tangible
sort of example where there's sort of a
collapse in diversity in a way in the
curriculum where because it is a limited
we do replay old levels but again it's a
limited finite buffer so you can get you
know sort of like a buffer overflow in a
sense of you know lots of levels that
collapse in terms of similar challenges
and then maybe the agent just gets too
good at going downhill jumping down
really challenging hills but then it
starts to the curriculum starts to
forget that also going uphill is also
important and maybe that's what happened
in some of these training runs
i i like the yeah
i like the approach i think poet or poet
v2 had some sort of an approach where
they do of course have different agents
but they had this metric of ranking the
environments that they have in the
buffer right and sort of ranking them
with respect to different agents and
their conclusion was that if
the if the different agents rank the
environments in a different way that
kind of indicates a diversity of levels
right whereas if they rank them the same
way it's kind of like well it's
they're not really diverse i think much
like your
regret measure i'm a big fan of these
they're not super domain independent but
they are domain independent enough right
so that you could like you can kind of
disconnect them from the real problem at
hand that's pretty cool
that one is definitely i think more
general um yeah i think that's quite an
exciting approach maybe if you wanted to
use population maybe even to generate
experiences then that's quite a nice um
way of evaluating the diversity i think
so is it fair to say that kind of the
end here like the the most let's say you
train this let's assume this is
convergence at 5 000 step that this is
kind of a
a representation
like it's it's almost like a fingerprint
of the agent's ability in the face of a
curriculum that tries to push harder and
harder right because there's a trade-off
the easy levels
not being in the buffer or not being
um yeah not being in the buffer means
they're easy they can be solved right
but then
also yeah this is it it seems like it
seems like this is the curriculum that's
needed
for the agent to be as general as
possible not necessarily as good as
possible
so yeah i think it's worth noting as
well that mint she added a really cool
feature to the website where you can
actually see five seeds of each method i
don't know if you've seen that version
but
you can see that the excel agents are
pretty remarkably similar
so they almost all seem to follow quite
a similar gate which makes me think that
this is kind of the solution that for
this network does cover the space as
best as possible
and so it might be the case maybe that
to get to get better behavior and better
performance
maybe you need to have a lego show all
seats maybe you need to have something
that's a little bit more flexible either
something with memory or i think i think
some some implementations for ipad
walker use frame stacking these types of
things maybe you can get more capacity
into the network um
that way and i think it's probably
possible or likely that um there you go
it's it's probably quite likely that um
this this is the best policy you can get
um with this network to have this max
regret um approach
yeah although there is one survivor
well we'll start we'll see
yeah excellent cool um
yeah the website is the website is
definitely pretty cool the last
interesting thing i've i found at least
for me here was this uh generalization
to the to the maze and
i mean it's it's very cool because you
you train on these um
on these
made-up mazes starting from empty rooms
and then you test on these kind of human
generated mazes right here and then you
generalize to this giant maze here now
you say yourself the agent seems to
follow this kind of bit of a left-hand
uh rule
how does something like this emerge
because it doesn't seem like in the
generated levels a left-hand rule would
be uh beneficial
because there's a lot of loops and stuff
in that like how does how does a
strategy like this emerge
i guess one thing that's quite worth
noting in this environment is partially
observable so
you only need to really generate a small
bit of structure within within the grid
for it to kind of generalize maybe to
larger grids but i think this is the
thing that's more apparent right
yeah exactly and that actually makes
this really hard so even for a human if
you imagine you didn't know where the
green dot was and try and do this as a
5000 humans would not be able to yeah
i certainly lost patience with it after
a couple of goes there's like a 5 000
step limit so it's quite long um but if
yeah if you look at the excel um sort of
towards the end of training as well in
the mini grid domain
um a lot of the levels so it ends up
converging towards around 60 block count
and that's sort of like the threshold
beyond which a lot of the
levels where you randomly sample like
more than 60 blocks they tend to be
unsolvable so they tend to have a block
preventing you from getting to the goal
and so 60 seems to be like the sweet
spot for a 15 by 15 maze and when you
get to that set like that amount of
saturation of blocks a lot of the levels
tend to actually become
uh effectively single component mazes
and so those are unsolvable by the left
hand rule so i think that's also like
just a contributing factor like some
property of the specific dimensionality
that we looked at resulted in you know
the complexity converging to like lots
of mazes that are single component and
it helps the agent basically learn this
left hand rule yeah it's pretty cool do
you i didn't dive too much into the
experimental results in my review uh is
there like what are some of the things
that you might want to highlight across
your experimental results maybe that
you've you find more interesting than
um the average person would when they
read the paper
i guess for me it's two things so
the first one is that the complexity is
entirely emergent so we never encourage
the agents to actually increase the
block count we never encourage it to
increase the stump height in the bipedal
walker it just has to do that to
increase regret
so some other papers maybe or works
maybe they have some like ways to
encourage this whereas we actually
didn't so if we were to do that maybe in
the future that's could even increase it
even further and then the second thing
is that all of the test cases are zero
shot evaluations so the agent's never
seen the test levels
um and i think it's quite remarkable how
robust it is in quite a wide range of
settings
um so that's probably the two takeaways
for me we also had some results in the
uh appendix where we actually
we also test the final excel bipedal
walker agent again on top of the poet
levels so uh
in poet actually they they publish a few
of the rose plots showing the
the different parameter settings for
bipedal locker uh for some of the
crazier environments and we actually
tested bipedal our bipedal walker with
excel on those environments um but it
actually it didn't perform very strongly
so it's what's interesting is i think
what's interesting about this result is
it sort of highlights this duality
between like
the goals of these two algorithms where
i kind of see excel as being on one side
of the spectrum which is about
robustness general robustness to
unknown environments and
poet be on the other side of spectrum
where it's focused on getting
specialists for basically finding these
agent environment specialist pairs where
this agent just always solves this
environment um
and so it's kind of an interesting
philosophical idea because it's kind of
saying that if you're building an ai
system do you really care about being
robust to things that you don't know
about or do you want to maximize your
performance uh as a specialist and
i think it's a really interesting open
question and the way we navigate this
trade-off i think is really full of rich
ideas for future research projects
yeah especially ideas that could combine
some of these things as well and we've
obviously talked about a lot of possible
things but um actually if you go but if
you go a little bit a few pages down
what we did was um we actually took the
some of the most complex levels that um
poet generates and then we produced we
produced them in our own setting and
that's also 100 by 100 maze if you're
interested
uh 100 by 100 did it solve it yeah
it has to be odd number for the for the
simulator to work but okay okay
that one against the eight percent
success rate on that one
uh it's i think a bit above this
uh table
yeah uh higher up
um maybe
yeah
what are you looking for the poets yeah
it should be a small it's like a very
small table um i think it's down below
search and the paper itself i guess
we should probably have paper up on our
own
screen but well my bad for not knowing
it too well
um oh yeah
potentially on the next page
the this is the like main experiments on
this i think it must be on the next
videos in the next page
yeah so 1a to 3b are in the paper
towards the end they have like a rose
plot for some of the most extremely
challenging levels that each of their
seeds generated so for all three of
their seeds they pick two different
levels that they're like particularly
high values and we tested our agent zero
shot on those
um
and yeah the scores are pretty low but i
think the fact that they're above zero
is cool but at the same time it does
make you think
that if they can solve those repeatedly
then
maybe you do need specialists in some
cases to get the most complex things so
some hybrid of specialists and
generalists might be an even more
powerful algorithm than either of them
combined
excellent um
so
you mentioned a bunch of different and
you also have a future work section and
so on what do you think are
apart from the things you're going to do
next what are like the big unsolved
challenges in the field like what's
what's everyone after but no one's been
able to do it so far
well so the big one is uh a theme that
we we as a group have gotten very
interested in uh recently and we're
actually holding a workshop at iclear
about this um and essentially it's about
uh
asian environment co-evolution but in
this in the context of this much older
problem called open-endedness
um and basically open-endedness is an
idea that um
it kind of came from a group of
researchers uh ken stanley joe layman
and jeff clin and i think jeff clinton
has this concept of ai generating ai and
it's related to this idea of
open-endedness where um can you
basically create a learning system that
essentially ends up evolving just an
unbounded amount of novelty and
complexity
and if you can kick-start a process that
achieves true open-endedness then the
idea is that maybe you can replicate the
emergence of some really complex
intelligences uh like human level
intelligence because evolution like the
tree of life this is all sort of uh the
result of an open-ended uh learning
process
and so a lot of where we see this work
going is that when we we see our work as
sort of fitting within this bigger theme
of open-endedness and this larger theme
of agent environment co-evolution to
achieve this open-endedness um
and so i think that that's sort of to me
is one of the most interesting open
problems um in ai or machine learning or
maybe it goes beyond even these two
subjects um
yeah so i think that if
we can actually kick off a process like
this that would be incredible and i'd be
very curious to see what kinds of things
fall out of it
yeah and for me the the thing i'm really
excited about is
that again tying in with minshees is
this seems like the only limitation to
this really being open-ended is
requirement for a simulator so i'm
really excited about whether we can
actually learn simulators for example
world models um so i was obviously very
inspired by the higher-end traditional
work from 2018
but more modern like offline rl uh world
models so maybe you have some
transformer world model that learns from
all this crazy amount of data and then
you can use that to design environments
for an rl agent and then collect more
data and just keep going and maybe
that's how you really get towards this
true open endemist because you're not
bounded by just the opening igm
environment that
that you're given
um and so this is maybe it's a little
bit more of a
uh the medium to long-term goal because
i think we're a bit away from that right
now but i think that that could be where
where these different fields like
intersect and really produce something
pretty pretty pretty crazy
yeah my issue a little bit with the uh
agent environment co-evolution work is
that it just seems to kind of shift the
problem away from because okay we're
evolving the environments right here but
they're still like extremely bounded in
an extremely parameterized space right
and and and there's only
like these many ways that the
environment can vary and the true
environment is kind of like the
environment generator itself and it
seems like
you know we could we could go a level
higher and so on but how is there a
method to
generally break out of this
uh
you know being bound to any framework
i think one way is um you know it's it's
related to what jack just described
which is this um so you've heard of sim
to real as the paradigm where you
explain intelligence in the simulation
you transfer to reality um and that's
obviously bounded by the fidelity of
your simulator for your target domain um
there's a new paradigm emerging uh and
it's like sort of pushed by all these
advances in computer vision uh which
some people have called real to sim to
real
and basically the idea that you can
essentially collect data in a loop where
you know you may have some exploratory
agent maybe it's a hand coded controller
or maybe it's an rl agent the one you're
training and you send it out into the
wild it collects lots of data about what
the world is like and then you use that
data to essentially enrich your
simulator to basically fit your
simulator to reality to all the new
things it's learned and then you get a
better more expansive simulator you
train your agent again in that simulator
and you get a new agent to transfer to
reality and then this loop just keeps
repeating and maybe you can do this in a
population of agents doing this uh and
you get really huge coverage in terms of
what's out there um i think that's one
promising way to do it uh the other
though is i think it kind of just
generally the strategy is like you said
all these simulators are bounded in
terms of their parametrization like we
are looking at 15 by 15 nases there's a
finite number of them um
i think what would be really cool is if
we started as rl researchers started
focusing more on environments that are
unbounded in parametrization so moving
into these like more almost
non-parametric settings where the
environment can just keep growing
arbitrarily in its number of parameters
um and i actually think the real
distinct real loop is one way to do that
just because the space of possible
worlds you can represent as a world
model as a neural network is is pretty
much infinite um but maybe there are
other simpler ways you could do this as
initial toy tests as well and then when
you have that real sim to real world
model you can then training mini max
regret policy inside it yeah
because then you have like this idea of
the population generating this diverse
you know very
high dimensional world model but then a
single agent maybe that could be
generally robust to any possible
variation in it
and so this is maybe a bit of a medium
term but yeah i think for us it's kind
of a north star at the moment
do you think there will ever be
sorry last question by me do you think
there will ever ever be this distinction
between agent and environment will will
this
continue to be an important distinction
or is that something that you see in the
future
vanish and and kind of almost become
like
let's say interchangeable because people
are already like pitting them against
each other training them both with rl
and so on like why do we even make the
distinction
well i guess one thing that's
interesting is even in the original
world models paper
um because the world model itself was
generated model the policy was very low
dimensional it just trained inside the
latent um state um latent space of the
work the generative model so then when
you actually interacted with the real
environment you still use the encoder
from the world model to process the
input so that the policy can then
operate and so in that sense it's like
the world model is the environment at
training time offline but then at test
time when you go back to the real
environment the world model is used to
process the inputs for the policy and so
they're kind of taking a very like i
guess competitive and then a cooperative
mindset
so i think maybe there's something like
that where you have world models that
are your environment for training time
but then you use them as knowledge bases
for test time
um
i think that's pretty exciting and it
also kind of relates this idea of the
cherry on top because the policy is very
small although i hate to hate to use too
many cliches but um it does seem to
relate to that sort of self-supervised
learning large world models and then rl
just for controllers inside that that
can operate on the representations uh i
don't mean
things for that well i i think to
sort of answer the other side of that
question i think that um
asian environment
i guess this distinction is
in some ways it's arbitrary because you
can imagine you know like what part of
this learning system actually belongs to
the agent um like is the agent really
like at the activation level is it at
the observation level like where do you
even draw the boundary in terms of the
agent um i think that's an interesting
question um but i also think that at
some point there's going to be some
substrate in which the agent has to
operate within and there seems to be um
like basically if you wanted to emerge a
diverse sort of uh you know tree of life
of different rl agents and environments
uh it seems like there is some sort of
asymmetry there in the sense that agents
have to operate within an environment
and you can't have it reversed um and so
in some to some extent i think we'll
still have to have this distinction
between agents and environments um
but it's also possible you know like
maybe we could also just learn you know
joint distributions over agents and
environments where you basically just
learn you know like the agents
parameters themselves are now part of
the environment design and so now you're
just emerging
agents and environments together inside
of a single generative model
um i think that's an exciting idea um
but and maybe at some point we'll figure
out how to do that
where can people get started with this
if they want to dive into it
so there's a great uh for open-endedness
there's a great uh primer to it uh on
o'reilly i can actually send you the
link after uh but it's written by um
some of the original sort of pioneers
within this field
and essentially it's quite long but it
summarizes the whole field um another uh
another really interesting uh work would
be i think just to check out the
original uh mini max regret paper for rl
which is this emerging complexity for
zero shot generalization uh from michael
dennis and natasha jacks and um
i would definitely recommend you know
our line of work uh with robust plr
checking out this paper and um there's
older methods like teacher student
curriculum learning from um
uh schumann's group at openai and
um the workshop yeah
so
we're going to have an uh iclear
workshop called agent learning and
open-endedness uh aloe and that's going
to feature a lot of uh speakers and
researchers uh actively
making progress in this field so if
people are really interested they should
uh attend some of the talks and check
out the poster session that'll be yeah
that's april 29th i think right april
29th yeah friday
good uh also more in a multi-agent
setting there's um the curriculum
learning manifesto from joel joe levo at
deepmind and
that has some really nice ideas in terms
of automatic curriculum learning merging
emergent complexity
cool
minty and
jack thank you very much for being here
this was really cool
thank you for having us
[Music]
you